l'actualité sportive les français sont
prêts à faire la courte échelle pour que
les petits de calais entre dans la
légende
plus de 60 % souhaitent leur victoire
tout à l'heure au stade de france
dans les rues de calais on se prépare à
l'événement l'ambiance est euphorique
comme s'ils la victoire était déjà à
portée de main sur place à new mourgues
dominique maes ils vont gagner
mais avant le match déjà les supporters
se font entendre début d'après midi à la
gare de calais la grande migration a
commencé six trains comme celui-là 300
car au total dix sept mille
inconditionnels en route pour le stade
de france c'est la journée du siècle et
ne leur parlez surtout pas d'une
possible 17,3 on n'est pas souvent mais
on est parent du bon sens la coupe est
affichée dans le dos les dix
commandements pour battre les canaris
nantais pas de débat à avoir un peu de
chance
gagner les derbys s'assurer la
suprématie régionale confirmés y croire
jusqu'à la dernière minute c'est un
espoir de l'attraction devra plus mais
les canaris
je nous amène à nous n'est gagné
dix sept mille petits chanceux mais pour
tous ceux qui restent à caler l'ambiance
est aussi dans la ville depuis 10 heures
ce matin
concert ininterrompu de klaxons
on est fiers parce que quand même une
équipe d'amateurs comme ça les
travailleurs et qu'ils arrivent à ce
point là ils ont toute la ville avec lui
on va gagner on est tous de la fête des
vieux voit mieux les jeunes démunis tout
petit elle éclaire tout le monde soit
heureux et est un livre attentivement
qu'elle est repeinte en trois couleurs
et ici on n'a pas du tout mais alors pas
du tout envie que la fête s'arrête